اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من تل ابيب اهلا بكم
مئات من الشهداء والجرحى في مجزرتي
للاحتلال في مدرستي الفاخوره وتل الزعتر
شمالي قطاع غزه وعشرات الشهداء والجرحى في
غارات على خان يونس والنصيرات
وحماس تقول انها ستحاسب اسرائيل على
مجرتها في الفاخوره وجرائمها بحق الاطفال
والمدنيين طال الزمن او قصر حسب تعبيرها
بعد حصار مستشفى الشفاء وتدمير معظم
اقسامه قوات الاحتلال تجبر المرضى
والنازحين والاطباء على اخلائه قصرا بعد
امهاله ساعه واحده ووزاره الصحه تؤكد
للجزيره بقاء 120 جريحا وخمسه اطباء داخل
المستشفى والمدير العام للمستشفيات بغزه
يقول ان سته من مرضى غسيل الكلى واثنين و
في العنايه المركزه استشهدوا وسط خلافات
في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يقدم
موعد اجتماع الكابينت الى اليوم لبحث دخول
كميات وقود الى قطاع غزه بطلب امريكي
وفاين انشال تايمز تكشف ان اسرائيل اقترضت
في الاسابيع الاخيره 6ه مليارات دولار
للمساعده في تمويل حربها سته شهداء في قصف
على مخيم بلاطه وقوات الاحتلال تقتحم
طوباس شمال الضفه الغربيه وبلده العيسويه
شمال القدس المحتله وتصيب عشرات من طلاب
مدرسه بالاختناق في حين اعتدى مستوطنون
مسلحون على المزارعين في قريه الساويه
جنوبي نابلس الى
اللقاء y